[Music]
[Applause]
we've got a real problem with math
education right now
basically no one's very happy
those learning it
think it's disconnected uninteresting
and hard
those trying to employ them think they
don't know enough
governments realize that it's a big deal
for our economies but don't know how to
fix it
and teachers are also frustrated
yet math
is more important to the world than any
point in human history
so at one end we've got falling interest
in education in math and at the other
end we've got a more mathematical world
a more quantitative world than we ever
have had
so what's the problem why is this chasm
opened up and what can we do to fix it
well actually i think the answer is
staring us right in the face
use computers
i believe that
correctly using computers
is the silver bullet for making math
education work
so to explain that let me first talk a
bit about what math looks like in the
real world and what it looks like in
education see in the real world
math
isn't necessarily done by mathematicians
it's done by geologists
engineers
biologists
all sorts of different people modeling
and simulation
it's actually very popular
but in education it looks very different
dumb down problems lots of calculating
mostly by hand
lots of things that seem simple and not
difficult like in the real world except
if you're learning it
another thing about math
math sometimes looks like math like in
this example here
and sometimes it doesn't like
am i
drunk then you get an answer that's
quantitative in the modern world you
wouldn't have expected that a few years
back
but now you can find out all about
unfortunately my weight is a little
higher than that but uh all about what
happens
so let's zoom out a bit and ask why are
we teaching people math
what's the point of teaching people math
and in particular why are we teaching
the math and in general why is it such
an important part of education as a sort
of compulsory subject
well i think there are about three
reasons
technical jobs
so critical to the development of our
economies
what i call everyday living
you know to function in the ever in the
world today you've got to be pretty
quantitative much more so than a few
years ago
you know figuring out your mortgages
being skeptical of government statistics
those kinds of things
and thirdly what i would call you know
something like logical mind training
logical thinking
over the years we've put so much in
society and to be able to process and
think logically it's part of human
society it's very important to learn
that math is a great way to do that
so let's ask another question
what is math what do we mean when we say
we're doing math or educating people to
do math well i think it's about four
steps roughly speaking
starting with posing the right question
what is it that we want to ask what is
it we're trying to find out here and
this is the thing most screwed up in the
outside world beyond virtually any other
part of doing math people ask the wrong
question and surprisingly enough they
get the wrong answer for that reason if
not for others
so the next thing is take that problem
and turn it
from a real world problem into a sort of
math problem
that's stage two
once you've done that then there's the
computation step turn it from that into
some answer in a mathematical form
and of course math very powerful at
doing that and then finally turn it back
to the real world did it answer the
question and also verify crucial step
now here's the crazy thing right
now in math education we're spending
about perhaps eighty percent of the time
teaching people to do step three by hand
yet that's the one step computers can do
better than any human after years of
practice
instead we ought to be using computers
to do step three
and using the students to spend much
more effort on learning how to do steps
one two and four conceptualizing
problems applying them
getting the teacher to run them through
how to do that it's a crucial point here
math is not equal to calculating
math is a much broader subject than
calculating now it's understandable that
this has all got
intertwined over hundreds of years there
was only one way to do calculating that
was by hand
but in the last few decades that has
totally changed we've had the biggest
transformation of any ancient subject
that i can ever imagine with computers
calculating was typically the limiting
step and now often it isn't
so i think in terms of the fact that
math has been liberated from calculating
but that math liberation didn't get into
education yet
see i think of calculating in sense as
the machinery of math it's the chore
it's the thing you'd like to avoid if
you can like to get a machine to do
it's a means to an end not an end in
itself
and automation allows us to have that
machinery computers allow us to do that
and this is not a small problem by any
means i estimated that just today across
the world we spent about 106 average
world lifetimes teaching people how to
calculate by hand
that's an amazing amount of human
endeavor
so we better be damn sure and by the way
they didn't have fun doing it most of
them
so we better be damn sure
that we know why we're doing that and it
has a real purpose
i i think we should be assuming
computers for doing the calculating and
only doing hand calculations where it
really makes sense to teach people that
and i think there are some cases
for example mental arithmetic i still do
a lot of that
mainly for estimating people say such
and such true and i think not sure i'll
think about it roughly it's still
quicker to do that more practical so i
think practicality is one case where
it's worth teaching people by hand
and then there are certain conceptual
things that can also benefit from hand
calculating but i think they're
relatively small in number
one thing i often ask about is ancient
greek and how this relates see
the thing we're doing right now is we're
forcing people to learn mathematics it's
a major subject
i'm not for one minute suggesting that
if people are interested in hand
calculating or unfollowing their own
interests in any subject how however
bizarre they should do that that's
absolutely uh the right thing for people
to follow their self-interest
i was somewhat interested in ancient
greek but i don't think that we should
force the entire population to learn a
subject like ancient greek i don't think
it's warranted so i have this
distinction between what we're making
people do and the subject that's sort of
mainstream and the subject that in a
sense people might follow with their own
interests and perhaps even be spiked
into doing that
so what are the issues people bring up
with this well one of them is they say
you need to get the basics first you
shouldn't use the machine until you get
the basics of the subject so my usual
question is what do you mean by basics
basics of what
are the basics of driving a car learning
how to service it or design it for that
matter
are the basics of writing learning how
to sharpen a quill
i don't think so i think you need to
separate the basics of what you're
trying to do
from how it gets done and the machinery
of how it gets done
an automation allows you to make that
separation you know 100 years ago it's
certainly true that to drive a car you
kind of need to know a lot about the
mechanics of the car and how the
ignition timing works and all sorts of
things
but automation in cars allowed that to
separate so driving is now a quite
separate subject so to speak
from
engineering of the car
or learning how to service it
so automation allows this separation and
also allows in the case of driving and i
believe also in the future case of mass
a democratized way of of doing that it
can be spread across a much larger
number of people who can really work
with that
so there's another thing that comes up
with basics people
confuse in my view the order of the
invention of the tools
with the order in which they should use
them for teaching
so just because paper was invented
before computers it doesn't necessarily
mean you get more to the basics of the
subject by using a computer using paper
instead of a computer to teach
mathematics
well my daughter gave me a rather nice
anecdote on this she enjoys making what
she calls paper laptops
so i asked her one day you know when i
was your age
i didn't make these why do you think
that was
and after a second or two carefully
reflecting she said no paper
[Applause]
if you were born after computers and
paper it doesn't really matter which
order you talk with them in you just
want to have the best tool so another
one that comes up is computers dumb math
down
that somehow if you use a computer it's
all mindless button pushing but if you
do it by hand it's all intellectual
this one kind of annoys me i must say
you know do we really believe
that the math that most people are
actually doing in school practically
today
is more than applying procedures to
problems they don't really understand
for reasons they don't get
i don't think so and what's worse what
they're learning there isn't even
practically useful anymore it might have
been 50 years ago
but it isn't anymore when they're out of
education they do it on a computer
so i just to be clear i think computers
can really help with this problem
actually make it more conceptual now of
course like any great tool they can be
used completely mindlessly like turning
everything into a multimedia show
like the example i've shown of solving
an equation by hand where the computer
was the teacher showed the student how
to manipulate and solve it by hand
this is just nuts
why are we using computers to show a
student how to solve a problem by hand
that the computer should be doing anyway
all
backwards let me show you that you can
also make problems harder to calculate
see normally in school
you do things like solve quadratic
equations
but
you see when you're using a computer you
can just substitute
you can make it a quartic equation make
it kind of harder calculating wise same
principles applied
calculations harder
and problems in the real world look
knotty and horrible like this they've
got hair all over them they're not just
simple dumbed down things that we see in
school math
and think of the outside world do we
really believe that engineering and
biology and all these other things
that have so benefited from computers
and maths have somehow conceptually got
reduced by using computers i don't think
so quite the opposite
so the problem we've really got in math
education is not that computers might
dumb it down
but that we have dumbed down problems
right
now well another issue people bring up
is somehow that hand calculating
procedures teach understanding so if you
go through lots of examples you can get
the art you can understand how the
basics of the system work better
i think there is one thing that i think
very valid here which is that i think
understanding procedures and processes
is important
but there's a fantastic way to do that
in the modern world
it's called programming
programming is how most procedures and
processes get written down these days
and it's also a great way
to engage students much more
and to check they really understand if
you really want to check you understand
math then write a program to do it
so programming is the way i think we
should be doing that so to be clear what
i really am suggesting here is we have a
unique opportunity to make math both
more practical and more conceptual
simultaneously
i can't think of any other subject where
that's recently been possible it's
usually some kind of choice between the
vocational and the intellectual
but i think we can do both at the same
time here
and
we open up so many more possibilities
you can do so many more problems what i
really think we gain from this is
students getting intuition and
experience in far greater quantities
than they've ever got before an
experience of harder problems being able
to play with the math interact with it
feel it we want people who can feel the
math instinctively that's what computers
allow us to do
another thing it allows us to do is
reorder the curriculum traditionally
it's been by how difficult it is to
calculate but now we can reorder it by
how difficult it is to understand the
concepts however hard the calculating so
calculus has traditionally been taught
very late
why is this well it's damn hard doing
the calculations that's the problem
but actually many of the concepts were
amenable to a much younger age group
this was a little example i built for my
daughter
and very very simple
you know we were talking about what
happens when you increase the number of
sides of a polygon
to a very large number
and of course it turns into a circle
by the way she was also very insistent
on being able to change the color
important feature for for this
demonstration
you can see that this is a very early
step into limits and differential
calculus and what happens when you take
things to an extreme and very small
sides and very large number of sides but
that very simple example that's a view
of the world that we don't usually give
people for many many years after this
and yet that's a really important
practical view of the world
so one of the roadblocks we have
in
moving this agenda forward
is exams in the end if we test everyone
by hand and exams it's kind of hard to
to get the curricular change to a point
where they can use computers during the
during the semesters
and one of the reasons so important so
it's very important to get computers and
exams and then we can ask questions real
questions
questions like what's the best life
insurance policy to get real questions
that people have in their everyday lives
you see this isn't some dumb down model
here this is an actual model where we
can be asked to optimize what happens
you know how many years of protection do
i need what does that do to the payments
and to the interest rates and so forth
now not for one minute suggestion is the
only kind of question that that should
be asked in exams
but i think it's a very important type
that right now just gets completely
ignored
and is critical for people's real
understanding
so i believe critical reform we have to
do in computer-based math we've got to
make sure
that we can move our economies forward
and also our societies based on the idea
that people can really feel mathematics
this isn't some optional
extra and the country that does this
first
will in my view leapfrog others
in achieving uh
a new economy even an improved economy
an improved outlook
in fact i even talk about us moving from
what we often call now the knowledge
economy
to what we might call a computational
knowledge economy where high-level math
is integral to what everyone does in the
way that knowledge currently is
we can engage so many more students with
this and they can have a better time
doing it
and let's understand
this is not
an incremental sort of change we're
trying to cross a chasm here between
school math and the real world math and
you know if you walk across a chasm you
end up making it worse than if you
didn't start at all bigger disaster
now what i'm suggesting
is that we should leap off we should
increase our velocity so it's high and
we should leap off one side
and go the other of course having
calculated our differential equation
very carefully
so i want to see a completely renewed
changed math curriculum built from the
ground up based on computers being there
computers that are now ubiquitous almost
calculating machines are everywhere and
will be completely everywhere in a small
number of years
now i'm not even sure if we should brand
this subject as math
but what i am sure is it's the
mainstream subject of the future
let's go for it
and while we're about it
let's have a bit of fun for us for the
students and for ted here
thanks
[Applause]
i'm doing the creative direction in the
magazine i work as a photographer i also
have been curating i do anything and
everything related to photography that i
can
dusty is a bi-annual art and culture
journal we know so many creative people
and we wanted to sort of give people a
forum to do projects that they might not
be able to do for other magazines
my blackberry works with my lifestyle
because i actually work from my phone
going back and forth with different
clients constantly if we're planning an
issue of the magazine i'm looking at
proofs on my phone the new one has a
keypad and then also a touchscreen i
really like the keypad i could not write
long emails on a phone that just had a
touch screen there's no way
i started taking pictures seriously when
i was about 17 but i just didn't think
it was going to be my job up until very
recently all of my personal work was
pictures of just like what was around me
if i'm sitting around with friends i
usually have my camera i take a picture
of what i see
bones
pony
[Music]
he's like i guess this is where you want
me
the quality of the camera on the
blackberry is definitely good enough
that i can do almost anything i want
online with it i contribute to a couple
different blogs aside from the dossier
blog a lot of times i'll just send them
pictures from wherever i am taken with
my blackberry this is rainbow eucalyptus
in maui
and it uh it grows by the side of the
road this is taken from the top of the
pompadou in paris it's the line to get
in
that's a hedgehog in the souk and
marrakesh it's the inside of my dog's
mouth i just travel a lot for work you
know
i have my phone with me everywhere i go
works anywhere in the world
and that's awesome
[Music]
you